as putin's war in ukraine rages on
there's one terrifying question hanging
over eastern europe how far will he go
in ukraine nato's hands are tied but
what if putin chooses to march on to the
baltic states to poland slovakia romania
or hungary there are worrying signs that
russia's leader might be willing to take
the ultimate gamble and risk a direct
confrontation with
nato so on another special edition of to
the point we ask putin's war is he
really threatening eastern europe
[Music]
welcome to to the point and here are my
guests today
daria suhachok a russian journalist
based in berlin working for osbest tv
and carolina vigorous sociologists and
journalists from poland also a fellow at
culturally liberal foundation in warsaw
and robert bosch academy here in berlin
i'm milan nitch from slovakia senior
fellow at the german council on foreign
relations a warm welcome to all of you
so this war has already had a profound
effect on
eastern european countries in many many
ways carolina you've just returned from
poland
yesterday i believe
tell me about what what you
felt there and what's what the mood is
like
so i felt immense uh amount of fear and
at the same time immense amount of
empathy so you have fear because if you
ask whether eastern europe will be
attacked by putin well vast part of the
eastern europe already thinks yes we are
already at war so there is this fear
which is connected with our geography
and also with the historical
experience of the region that tells us
if ukraine's on fire then we are going
to be on fire very soon you have written
in an article about the
re-traumatization of eastern europe by
this war what do you mean
we mean that we basically think in
poland that we see in ukraine both our
past and our future we see the past
because we see the dormant imperialism
of russia coming back again and again
throughout the last 300 years but it
could be also potentially future this is
why people
already are feeling a lot of fear
although they fight with this fear with
empathy with empathy towards the
refugees
compared to the population slovakia at
the moment takes uh the largest share of
refugees
uh
well if you don't count moldova
uh a country of two and a half million
that has the same amount of refugees as
my my home country slovakia um 200 000
now and growing but i wouldn't single
out any country because this is now
as the uh u.n commissioner for refugees
felipe granty said the fastest-growing
refugee crisis in europe
since second world war so more than
bosnian war more than wars in former
yugoslavia that had smaller number and
started gradually this this is
unprecedented in the pace of when this
war was by surprise started on the what
is now two weeks ago
and now we have two million people on
the move and this is before the shelling
of kiev really started there will be
more there will be millions of more in
the coming days or weeks i'm afraid
uh refugees alike which are already
aside which already
affects
the the countries that that take take
them in but with respect with regard to
what carolina just said uh what's the
mood like in slovakia is it similar to
the mood in poland
carolina described you very well i'm not
there i am here although on the phone uh
and through social media with my friends
and family i think there is a profound
confusion
there is fear there is also empathy
there is now a big wish to help
ukrainians that are that are that are
escaping
also
to to do the right thing unlike in 2015
i think a lot of people a lot of my
friends really want to be on the border
to to help i don't know how the
capacities they will cope
so i brought to the studio
leaflet that is that is distributed also
in ukrainian at the border
with slovakia
um
informing ukrainians about their rights
uh that are provided now they have
temporary protection this is
unprecedented this is fast but
will will it how long will it last if
you have only a limited number of beds
limited number of uh immediate
facilities so in a way i feel strange
sitting here in the studio and not being
there as a volunteer on the border
because we see them as
we feel tremendous solidarity with
ukrainians they are not part of the eu
but they are people like us they're part
of europe
and they are they are attacked and i
have to say also with darya in the
studio i feel tremendous solidarity with
russians
that are
not behind this that are not supporting
putin because this is also a domestic
war on
on russians by the kremlin it's
interesting that you mentioned that
daria um you are russian you're a
journalist you're based in berlin and
earlier as we spoke you told me that
you're now a criminal yeah i am i'm a
criminal facing in the worst case up to
20 years in jail for
donating to ukrainian humanitarian
relief among other things while being a
russian citizen that constitutes the
criminal offence of treason i have
committed a number of other crimes
including joining a protest against the
war and spreading the so-called
fakes
aka truth about the war in ukraine which
is now also criminal offense from which
journalists especially are suffering in
russia and
two days ago i have seen a count on one
of the very few independent journalistic
projects left in russia that at least
150 journalists have left russia already
since the beginning of the war
but obviously this number can be a lot
higher because many of those people are
not really properly counted there is no
official register of journalists and how
many of them are leaving or not but this
is what the people from
that project managed to count on social
media because obviously not all the
journalists announced that they're
leaving on social media
uh quite many just let their friends
know but it is physically dangerous to
be journalists in russian now and cold
war war and not the special operation as
the official term demands yeah so you
know my just a migrant at them or you're
an exile an official exile are you still
in touch with your friends and family in
russia and tell us about the civil
society in russia
how is this war being viewed there
i am in touch with my
friends and family in russia some have
also left the thing is that obviously
leaving rush is not an easy feat because
unless you have i am very privileged
person because i have my permanent
residency germany i have my work visa
i'm allowed to where i can live here no
one's going to kick me out of here
unless i commit some crimes here in
germany and become a true career
seasoned criminal
but
the thing is that you need a work visa
to enter germany or a study visa or
anything like that
and a lot of gen of russians don't have
it so many have left to the neighboring
countries which have visa-free regime
with russia like kazakhstan
uh turkey partly some people are in
egypt also of course countries in the
caucasus like azerbaijan georgia armenia
central asia
even countries like uzbekistan and
tajikistan which were previously viewed
as very
undesirable places to live in right now
they are seeing a massive influx of
russian citizens
who are
going there some are saying well we'll
wait it out we'll try to do our jobs
we'll see
what we can do right now
and we'll maybe we'll look for jobs
somewhere else but for now we just want
to be out of harm's way just to make
sure that we're not going to be detained
tomorrow
for
anything i don't know if we're wearing a
badge saying no to war or something this
is also an offense
so
civil society all these countries uh uh
are affected russia included um
what about uh
support the support that you
feel that you will be getting in that
role as front line states
from the west from nato what do you what
do slovakians
feel
well
if we put aside your original question
at the beginning of this program about
security
the immediate i think there are two
three issues that
affect the current situation these days
these weeks one is
the
uh humanitarian help with the flux of
refugees many of them just go through
these countries but a lot of them stay
in poland there are two million
ukrainians so they have friends of
families prague is a city running on
ukrainians uh budapest my friends
they're in spite of the
pro-russian policy of the urban
government is full of ukrainians so
there is immediate relief and material
help more than demands for
redistribution of these refugees because
many of them will go to their families
on the other side of europe second is
the direct impact of
sanctions on russia especially if it
will go to oil and gas will be felt in
in these countries of central and
eastern europe they are much more
vulnerable
because of their energy mix because of
higher uh percentage up to 100 percent
in hungary of russian gas and the third
is russian disinformation which is fed
by
by various alternative media
a very active russian embassies there
and you simply have a match of
part of the political spectrum which is
uh
which is far-right or or extremist and
full of resentment and they click with
part of the population and now
fed with some narratives that are
very anti-western
um and somehow
not ag against
um ukraine 90 of slovaks is uh really
thinking that that russia
did an unprovoked aggression on ukraine
so it's difficult to go against the wind
but you have
you have poking into the whole
democratic structure of these countries
and societies from various ways and this
is long term this is not only happening
now so
the vulnerabilities that are there are
not only about this week but longer term
and i would i would end up by saying
that also this country germany is
sending its soldiers i think 700
to slovakia as part of for uh
forward present
at the eastern flank of nato members
at the borders of uh
ukraine uh russia and villains
so the
the uh
on the polish side uh we have seen this
week that poland offered to send fighter
jets
in a bit of a strange move via germany
by a u.s base in in germany and to be
transferred
to ukraine but the us has said it
doesn't want it does poland still feel
supported by the u.s so there are two
things that we have to mention first is
pacts and of course nato is a pact in
which every member
should feel safe because of the article
5 and it's extremely important that we
remember that but on the other hand this
war is a war on emotions and
disintegration
and disinformation
so you have the pact and you have on one
side and the other side is the history
of being being always in the region that
is ever again attacked by the imperial
russia there is this old saying in
eastern and central europe they are
going to abandon us again so
you have you have this and of course you
have the russian disinformation i think
there is a lot by the way to learn from
2015
indeed because we we see now tremendous
empathy in in our plans you mentioned
two
million of ukrainians in poland already
three and a half because already 1.5
million arrived
within the last two weeks so so we have
a tremendous help and empathy but the
the disinformation of russia will be not
dormant they will work and i think they
will work on divisions in society on
radicalizing the the far right in order
to to make this whole picture not as
pretty as it is now you just mentioned
something very interesting uh they will
abandon us again and i believe we have a
um senpai prepared from the u.s
secretary of state anthony blinken with
regard to that let's uh listen into that
if we can
we will defend every inch of nato
territory against aggression
coming from anywhere
at any time
our commitment to article 5
an attack on one is an attack on all
is ironclad
the president has called it sacrosanct
and no one
no one should have any doubt about that
so a big promise there from anthony
blinken uh
do you feel much safer now after this
yes i do and not only after this
um i understand polish sentiment from
history because they were abandoned
several times problem didn't exist on
the map for 200 years it was partitioned
among
austria russia prussia
in slovakia in my country the feeling is
different
we are not so much we didn't feel before
the world to be so much exposed as a
neighbor of ukraine
it still is not war is not over it's
something else to have a
russian military sitting at the border
with
my country hungary and so on
and threatening and something else if
it's bogged down in ukraine
and i think ukraine is now fighting a
fight for all central eastern europe for
eu as well for the eu because
um
as members of nato and the eu if
poland or slovakia is attacked
everybody's attacked germany is in war
so the whole thing about
about fighter jets that you mentioned is
very sensitive extremely sensitive also
from police side
it's very complicated issue also
in terms of how you can you can deploy
it effectiveness communication system of
these jets but also
from where they will they will go
because moscow is threatening any
country any neighboring country
including romania most lately two days
ago the russian ministry of defense said
that they have reliable information that
ukrainian fighter jets are landing on
ukrainian airports and ukrainian
ukrainians or romanian air bases and
this can potentially be viewed as
romania during the war and this is a
very open threat from russia they
haven't seen they are already seeing it
as a threat but
they're hinting at it right so you have
a very very fine line very very timid
very delicate line to to to navigate
here at the same time when rockets are
fired to ukrainian airfields even from
transistoria so from another country
which is not part of the war the
occupied transistoria in moldova that i
mentioned so it's it's all paradox is
happening it's full of paradox is
happening very fast it's history in the
making
but i want to underline that um
i think there is a big division between
countries in central eastern europe that
are members of nato and eu and those who
are not and i feel
i i i really
if i were moldovan or georgian i would
be extremely worried now and i would
very much hope that the
the the whole battleground the the
fighting is is only concentrated in
ukraine i think it's very important what
you're saying because it's about
where this is heading next right so we
have seen the logic of of putin's
behavior
is clear it started with chechnya he
went to georgia he went to donbass and
now he's in ukraine so he has to go
further it's it's it's logical would you
agree but but
let me just mention the baltic states
because the prime minister of estonia
kanya kayakalas she was reminding it
very many times that the estonians
already feel threatened even though they
are a nato member country
would you agree is
explain putin to us you're the russian
at the table i know it's i know it's a
bit of an ask but
is he would you could he be willing to
confront nato
that's a good question because i don't
think there is a person in the world
left who could explain what putin thinks
because his brain is not only a black
box it's a black box within a
transparent tube because not only do we
not know how he thinks and what he
thinks we also don't know what kind of
information he's getting so since we
cannot see the input we cannot possibly
predict the output of his thinking
however
i do think that he's thinking in this
very expansionist logic this very
post-imperial he seems to have mentally
being in about 1856 right now
and uh i do think moldova might
potentially or
georgia armenia by the way let's not
forget armenia and azerbaijan where
there is already the russian forces
controlling the karabakh uh the disputed
territory between armenia and zerbaijan
there is a big russian military presence
in caucasus anyway and putin has already
attacked georgia in 2008. so um
it's kind of a well-thrown pass for him
already by now if i may or however in
the in the north karabakh you have
turkey directly involved so russia
played against this uh this deal with
turkey but um coming back to what
vladimir putin actually said or wrote
there is an essay
out there by him on ukraine uh back in
july last year we should come back to
reread it
um on ukraine it's almost like mine
comes from the kremlin exactly and it's
about ukraine
and
by by mistake i think some russian media
published also
uh after the war one day after the war
uh with this this this statement that
was maybe prepared after fast defeat of
ukraine which stated that russia belarus
and ukraine are together again to form a
sort of a post-soviet slavic core
and i think it's important for people to
go back to maps and history and see
where the soviet union you know ended so
the baltic countries that you mentioned
they're small they're part of nato and
the eu but they were part of the soviet
union i think by now kremlin draw the
line they understand that it's a
different game there
but
everything from post soviet from former
soviet union that is not in nato and eu
is to be
i think they want to be consulted about
their future their future uh not only
military uh sort of insecurity
arrangements but also trade arrangements
it all started in ukraine with the eu
association agreement back before 2014
not with uh
future of nato i think that's just the
pretext so let me make this point that
this is also about values i said
previously that this is about pacts and
this is al already very important pact
soon servanda right but uh values are
very important here because if you look
at those central and eastern european
countries that are either nato members
or not they they share a kind of nervous
sense of their cells this is because
they have been losing sovereignty many
many times in their history and
regaining
and so those those fears are about two
logics of international order either we
think in the uh in the categories of
spheres of influence and then we can
agree with mr putin we can say of course
the big
countries can decide what the small
countries are doing but if we believe in
values like democracy and the rule of
law then we also believe in
self-determination of a given nation
this is what the ukrainians are fighting
for right they are fighting for the fact
that they have been westernizing this
society for 30 years and now they would
like to have the fruit so
so i i do understand that that there is
this pact and i i completely believe mr
blinken
but on the other side there are also
emotions and motivations in politics and
international order so many many nations
when they observe what is happening
today in ukraine they say well this
society would like to have democracy and
see what happens and the west is
what
sending some arms perhaps isn't it too
too little
this is the biggest question of today i
think it goes down to whether you can be
independent
in the sphere of influence of one
country that is uh
trying to claim it's more than sphere of
influence it's it's fear where it
decides or co-decides with these small
countries and moscow the current
leadership of russia has not accepted
the existence of small
nations small countries that they have
the right to go where they want yeah i
would like to before we continue on that
i i would like to sort of take one step
further
and go
to the point where
what happens after this let's assume
this crisis is resolved in one way or
another
um
carolina you wrote in this war that
this war could reinforce the region's
turn towards nationalism
um
just
talk a bit more about that fear is not a
good advisor
and
even though i i do believe that the
poland's way of democratic
transformation after 1989 was the best
possible
uh that we can choose
in in in those situations when
there are fears
about the the future
even populist uh governments can gain uh
popularity regain popularity because war
usually brings more popularity to a
given government even it's if it's if
it's a populist one question though that
i find very important as well and i
might direct that to daria what can
russia do if this crisis is resolved one
way or another
what can how long will it take for
russia to return from international
pariah which it is right now
to become a partner for
in the international order well i think
there are many factors influencing this
and not the least of them is the energy
prices
obviously if the world is in a very dire
need of oil and gas this is good for
russia
the question is how much because we can
see europe and u.s and uk
trying to get off this needle but we
don't know how long it will take we
honestly cannot especially eastern
european countries we just didn't have
the time yet to adapt
to the new reality of the 21st century
uh in terms of an international pariah i
think it depends on how long putin will
remain in power and i don't think
anybody can really predict that
i
have experienced horrible disappointment
because until very lately i have been
hoping that there is a possibility of
some kind of peaceful transition that
putin might
want to strike some kind of balance with
the civil society and say hey guys you
could have your
little independent media your echo
screen youtube rain the tv channel and
the radio station that were closed by
the way on one day on the same day
about a week ago if i am not mistaken
10 days later in the first days of war
for exactly that for covering the war as
it is
uh but we see that he's turning into the
good old-fashioned 20th century dictator
who is probably going to quote mr
lukashenko uh cling onto power until his
fingers turn blue
and
we don't know how long this will take
and i cannot see the western countries
signing some kind of trade agreements
with putin again now he's so absolutely
and completely discredited and we all
know by now that signing anything with
the russian government is signing it
with putin essentially he's the sole
ruler of it
one last question very briefly please
can the west can nato return to business
as usual if this crisis is resolved
briefly it will be different nato uh and
on russia and ukraine i think the
biggest question here is what will be
their relations in the future the
country of 150 million and country of 40
million the two largest countries in the
east
think about on a good in a good way
serbia and croatia after their war but
on a much larger scale
i'm afraid we have to leave it here many
many open questions uh i'd love to go on
uh but we have to leave it right here
i'd like to thank my guests and uh thank
you all uh for watching to the point
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you